salut aujourd'hui je suis à amsterdam
[Musique]
alors ce soit bien clair la seule drogue
qui m'intéresse à amsterdam si vous
m'avez suivi sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est le fromage
j'aime le gouda c'est comme ça le
bouddha et moi c'est une histoire
d'amour et si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je joue une date de mon
spectacle ce soir mais j'en profite
aussi pour vous faire vandales blog
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer
comment faire un tour moitié magie à
moitié mentalisme pour bluffer les gens
pour noël c'est un petit peu le thème de
ce cas partout autour de moi mais
écoutez bien jusqu'à la fin je vous
donner quelques infos importantes par
rapport à ça et deux trois petits trucs
pour la chaîne c'est pas un endroit
tellement génial pour faire cette vidéo
pour vous expliquer le tour je vais vous
le faire une fois l'idée c'est pas
forcément de vous bluffez c'est bien de
vous expliquer un tour que vous allez
pouvoir vaut faire on n'est pas en
combat on n'est pas un duel vous et moi
imaginer que pour noël santa claus mais
donner 20 sucre d'orge g20 sucre d'orge
invisible juste là dans ma main vous
allez en prendre un certains nombres pas
beaucoup non plus hein vous n'oubliez
pas tout le stock vous en prenez un
petit peu vous comptez combien vous en
avez et vous retenez combien vous en
avez ça c'est important une fois que ça
c'est fait vous aviez que j'avais vingt
sucre d'orge dans ma main vous m'en avez
pris un certain nombre
vous comptez combien il m'en reste et
vous allez réduire ce nombre si vous
regardez des vidéos vous savez ce que ça
veut dire réduire ces taxis m'en reste
13 vous faites un +36 mort est 19 vous
faites un + 9 simon reste 10 vous faites
un + 0
[Musique]
ceux ci étaient intermèdes poétiques
donc vous savez combien de sucre d'orge
vous m'avez pris vous saviez combien il
m'en reste et vous réduisez le chiffre
du nombre de sucre d'orge qu'il bosse
maintenant vous reprenez dans ma main
autant de sucre d'orge que le chiffre
réduit que vous venez de calculer si le
chiffre réduit c'était 2 vous me
reprenez deux sucres d'orge et vous les
additionner au vote que vous avez déjà
pris ça fait des petits sucre d'orge en
plus et dans votre main vous avez
forcément maintenant un nouveau nombre
de sucre d'orge évidemment et c'est ce
nombre qui est important parce que ce
nombre il est à vous il dépend de
combien vous en avez pris au départ et
pourtant je sais déjà qu'elle est ce
résultat il suffit d'ouvrir la main pour
bien voir que ces 11
vous avez 11 sucre d'orge dans la main
c'est ce qu'on appelle un forçage
mathématiques comme certains que je vous
ai déjà appris cette année trois choses
à rajouter pour améliorer tout ça déjà
ne négligez pas les forçages
mathématiques ça peut être un bon point
de départ d'andy mentalisme pour savoir
à peu près où la personne en effet à
partir de ce onze
vous pouvez peut-être organiser quelque
chose de plus mentalist hic prendre des
risques sur un autre effet regardé dans
la playlist des explications de tour des
effets qui sont sans filet et vous savez
qu'au final il ya une information que
vous avez qui sera bonne ce sera ce
forçage mathématiques deuxième chose
c'est que pour que ça fonctionne il faut
qu il vous en reste entre 10 et 20 dans
la main donc vous pouvez demander
clairement à la personne oui je recule
parce que ça c'est quand même très joli
est-ce que j'ai plus de sucres d'orge
que toi ou est-ce que tu en as plus que
moi et en fonction de sa réponse la
personne devra réduire son nombre à elle
est ensuite en remettent dans votre main
et c'est vous qui aurez 11 ou l' inverse
c'est peut-être pas très claires dit
comme ça mais rappelez-vous de la
démonstration que je viens de vous faire
à l'instant réduit le nombre de sucre
d'orge de la personne à qui il reste le
plus mais en utilisant le texte comme
j'ai utilisé la personne n'en prendra
pas beaucoup elle en prendra moins de 10
troisième point moult important
également
vous n'êtes pas du tout ghz et
d'utiliser des sucres d'orge à vous
pouvez utiliser un paquet de chewing gum
ou et utiliser n'importe quoi même des
choses réelles
le mieux c'est de le faire dans
l'imaginaire comme je lé fais mais
utiliser l'objet que vous voulez ça me
faisait marrer d'utiliser des sucres
d'orge parce que je me dis vous pourrez
le faire un noël comme ça y'a pas besoin
d'objets il ya besoin de rien vous
pouvez le faire comme ça cache
concernant les forçages mathématiques je
vous ai dit ne négligez pas ça en plus
c'est quand même assez drôle à pratiquer
on peut le détourner de plein de
manières différentes
il ya un super bouquin que je viens de
découvrir sont pas des maths pur c'est
un peu comme on a fait ça permet
de voir les choses autrement je vous le
mets ici en vigne est également en lien
dans la description et concernant le jeu
que j'avais organisé lundi dernier pour
les 900 milles abonnés et bien j'arrête
les inscriptions ce soir donc vous avez
toujours le lien également dans la
description ce soir s'est terminé après
on va commencer à procéder aux envois
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu une
explication lundi jamais fait ça
pourquoi pas si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas laisser un pouce en l'air
c'est toujours important pouvez aussi
donner vos idées de mise en scène dans
les commentaires comment vous rêvez
lauriers ce chiffre et pourquoi pas en
faisant sonner une cloche en soi donc je
disais dans les commentaires vous pouvez
mettre vos idées de mise en scène vous
pouvez mettre tout ce que vous voulez
améliorer un peu les faits le rendre
encore plus gros ou le lier à d'autres
explications tour que j'avais fait dans
cette année le portez vous bien bons
préparatifs de noël n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner avant de partir et il le
vend elle boxe est toujours une vidéo
par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au
31 décembre
et ça ça arrive pas en 2017 rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao
voilà
[Musique]